thanks Darren and Larry and Dustin I
couldn't think of three people I'd
rather have given me this Oscar I'd like
to thank the Board of Governors of the
Academy for selecting me for this
prestigious and humbling honor this
night means so much to me
and my heartiest congratulations to the
other nunneries I can't begin to tell
you how thrilled I am to be here tonight
among so many extraordinary artists my
dear friend from New York dick DiBona
back in the early 70s based on my
commercial work recommended me to Billy
freaking to shoot the French Connection
and the rest is history when I first
started shooting features an old
stagehand told me that he thought it was
Orson Welles who said you know this is a
very collaborative effort making movies
film is made up of many tiny silver
particles and each one of those
particles is represented by every person
who works on the film you can imagine
how many different people I've worked
with and had you changed any one of them
on any movie the movie would have looked
different I had the great fortune to
work with so many artists and
visionaries produces writers directors
production designers set decorator
scripts gaffers the list goes on and on
and of course my wonderfully talented
camera crews I can't take the time to
name everybody but collectively
I can thank everybody I'm grateful for
all these wonderful collaborators I've
had over the years who have contributed
to the composition focus lighting and
movement of my work I would be remiss if
I didn't mention all of the brilliant
actors and actresses I had the
opportunity to photograph during the
course of my career I want to mention my
son Erik
who has followed in my footsteps which I
guess miss mean that I'm some kind of
decent role model right
so you can call them you know it's
finally and most especially thanks to my
gorgeous Swedish wife Mona who has been
my rock for all this time I'm extremely
grateful for this special honor thank
you very much
[Applause]